why do we think that stories by men are
deemed to be of universal importance and
stories by women are thought to be
merely about women my grandmother left
school when she was 12 she had 14
children my mother left school when she
was 15 to a secretary I graduated from
university to become a theatre director
and that progress is entirely to do with
the fact that people I'll never meet
fought for women to have rights get the
vote
get education have progress and I'm
determined to do the same and obviously
you are too why not
so I started a festival called Wow
where in the world seven years ago and
it's now in 20 countries across five
continents and one of those countries is
Somaliland in Africa so I traveled there
last year and part of the joy I had in
going there with going to these caves
the delis came now these caves contain
some of the oldest cave paintings in the
world these paintings are thought to be
round about 9,000 to 11,000 years old
art what humanity has done ever since it
involved it's how we speak about
ourselves how we understand our identity
how we look at our surroundings who we
find out about each other because of the
meaning of our lives of her artists for
so look at this little picture I think
it's a little girl I thought it was a
bit like me when I was a little girl and
then I thought well who painted this
joyful youthful figure and I asked the
curator of the caves I said tell me
about the men and women who painted
these and he looked at me absolutely
askance and he said women didn't paint
these pictures and I said well it was
eleven thousand years ago
I said how do you know and he said women
don't do these things men made these
marks women don't now I wasn't really
surprised because that's an attitude
that I've seen continuously all my life
as a theater major we are told that
divine knowledge comes down through the
masculine whether it be to the Imam the
priest the rabbi the holy man and
similarly we're told the creative genius
resides in the masculine that it is a
masculine that will be able to tell us
about who we really are that the
masculine will tell the universal story
on behalf of all of us whereas women
artists will really just talk about
women's experiences women's issues only
really relevant to women on a passing
interest to men and really only some men
and it's that conviction that that we
are taught that I think colors so much
of whether were prepared to believe that
women stories really matter unless of
imperatively that women stories really
matter then women's right those really
matter and then change can't really come
I want to tell you about two examples of
stories that are thought to be of
universal importance ET and Hamlet
so I took my two children when they were
little
Caroline was eight and Robbie with five
to see et and it's a fantastic story of
this little alien who ends up in an
American family with a mum two brothers
and sister but he wants to go home not
only that but some really bad scientists
want to do some experiments on him and
they're looking for him so the children
have a plot the Desai's are going to
take him back to his spaceship as soon
as they can and they plop them in a
bicycle basket and off they ride but
unfortunately the baddies have found out
and they're catching up on they've got
Cylons and they've got their guns we got
the loudhailer it's very frightening and
they're closing up on the children and
the children are never going to make it
then all of a sudden magically the bikes
fly up in the air over the clouds over
the moon and they're going to save ET so
I turned to see my children's faces and
Robbie is enraptured he's there with
them he's saving eat eat he's a happy
boy and I turned to Caroline and she's
crying her eyes out I think what's the
matter
she said why can't I save a plea why
can't I come and then all of a sudden I
realized they weren't children they were
boys all boys and Caroline who'd
invested so much in ET well she wasn't
invited to save him and she felt she
Lily ated and spurned so I wrote a
Steven Spielberg
[Music]
[Applause]
and I said I don't know if you
understand the psychological importance
of what happened and are you prepared to
pay for the therapy bills 20 years later
I haven't had a word back from him when
I'm still hopeful what I thought it was
interesting if if you read reviews of
what he intended with ET he says very
specifically I wanted the world to
understand but we should love and
embrace difference but somehow he didn't
include the idea of girls difference in
this thinking he thought he was writing
a story about all humanity Caroline
thought he was marginalizing half of
humanity he thought he was writing story
about human goodness she thought he was
writing aloud heroic adventure and this
is common men feel they have been given
the mantle for universal communication
but of course how could they be they are
writing from male experience through
males eyes we have to have a look at
this ourselves
we have to be prepared to go back for
all our books and our films or our
favorite things and say actually this is
written by a male artist not an artist
we have to see that so many of these
stories are written through a male
perspective which is fine but then
females have to have 50% of the rights
for the stage the film the novel the
place of creativity let me talk about
Hamlet to be or not to be that is the
question but it's not my question my
question is why would I taught of a
young woman that this was the
quintessential example of human dilemma
and human experience
it's a marvelous story but actually it's
about a young man fearful but he won't
be able to make it as a powerful figure
in a male world and that he takes
revenge for his father's murder
he talks a great deal to us about
suicide being an option
but the reality is that the person who
actually commits suicide a failure after
she's been humiliated and abused by him
never gets a chance to talk to the
audience about her feelings and then
when he finished with Ophelia he turned
on his mum because basically she has the
audacity before in love with his uncle
and enjoy sex it is a great story but it
is a story about male conflict male
dilemma male struggle but I was told
this was the story of human beings
despite the fact that it only had two
women in it and unless I react eight
myself I am always going to think that
women's stories matter less than men's a
woman could've written Hamlet but she
would have written it differently and it
wouldn't have had global recognition as
the writer Margaret Atwood says when a
man writes about doing the dishes its
realism when a woman writes about doing
it it's an unfortunate genetic
disposition now this is not just
something that belongs to them I mean
when I was a young girl wanting
desperately a theater director this is
what my male lecturer said to me well
there are three women directors in
Britain he said dude this Joe Knight is
a lesbian this Joan Littlewood who's
retired and there's both Goodbody who's
just killed herself so which of those
three would you like to be now leaving
aside the disgusting floor on gay women
the fact is he wanted to humiliate me he
thought it was silly that I wanted to be
a director and I told my friend Marin
Alsop the conductor and she said oh yes
well my music teacher said exactly to
say women don't conduct but all these
years later and we've made our mark you
think we'll be different now I'm afraid
is not different now the current head of
the Paris Conservatoire said recently it
takes great physical strength and up to
symphony and women are too weak
the artist George battle Nick said well
fact is women can't paint well they
can't paint very well the right of the
editor Paul said two years ago
I can read two paragraphs from though
immediately that's written by a woman
and I just stopped weaving because it's
not worthy of me and it goes on we have
to find a way of stopping young girls
and mooing feeling not only their story
doesn't matter but they're not allowed
to be the storyteller because once you
feel that you can't stand in this
central space and speak on behalf of the
world you will feel that you can offer
your goods up to a small select group
you will tend to do smaller work on
smaller stages your economic power will
less your reach of audiences will be
less and your credit will be less as an
artist and we do finally give artists
these incredible prominent spaces in the
world because they are our storytellers
now why should it matter to you if
you're not an artist supposing you're an
accountant or an entrepreneur or a medic
or a scientist should you care about
women artists absolutely you must
because as you can see from the cave
paintings all civilizations all of
humanity have relied upon artists to
tell the human story and if a human
story is finally told by men take my
word for it it will be about men so
let's make a change let's make a change
to all our institutions and not just in
the West don't forget this message of
incapability of women to hold creative
genius it's being told to girls women
Nigeria in China
in Russian in random Asia all over the
world girls and women are being told
that they can't finally hold the idea of
creative inspiration I don't want to ask
you do you believe that do you believe
that women come
a creative genius well then please go
forward support women artists by their
work insists that their voices are heard
find platforms on which their voices
will be made and remember this but in a
sense if we're going to get past this
moment of a world where we know that
we're an equal it artists who have to
imagine a different world and I'm
calling on all artists women and men to
imagine a gender equal world let's paint
it let's draw it let's write about it
let's film it and if we could imagine it
then we would have the energy and the
stamina to work towards it when I see
this little girl 11,000 years ago I want
to know that the little girl now and
stand there and think she's entitled her
dreams she's entitled to her destiny and
she's entitled to speak on behalf of the
whole world be recognized for it and
applauded thank you
[Applause]
[Music]